[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
20 strong chess players from nine
Federation's compete in st. Louis u.s.
chess champs calm presents the third
annual winter chess classic
[Music]
hello chess fans welcome back to st.
Louis it's hump day here at the winter
chess classic I'm Ben Simon joined by
former US Women's Champion Wilma
grandmasters sabina voyagers Sabina
it should be a fun day today I think so
I'm really looking forward to seeing
some of the games I can't wait but I
think we have to go over some details
first we'll just wait just a little bit
let's see our standings in our master
section group a here at the classic for
the first time we have a clear first
leader in Renata Juma buyeth with three
points good start for him we have yet to
speak with him in the tournament but no
doubt he'll be down here in the studio
soon what are your thoughts so far in
this field Sabina for sure that was it
might be an unexpected change of events
yesterday when we signed off with Caleb
we thought that in that game that he
played against Vera Cobian that game
should end in a draw but then somehow at
some point Vaart blundered and that made
me not you know being the leader of this
tournament but we've seen so many
amazing games by Geoffrey Zhang by
Oparin by caboose Ian and and yesterday
a very interesting turn of events in the
game I think those play between cerimon
and Viktor Erdos where Viktor seem to
have miscalculated and just dropped his
queen so a lot of really exciting chest
in this a group and I can't wait to see
what's happening today these games and
now let's jump over to our B group where
we also have a well well we oh pardon me
I was looking at these super live
standings the live live stuff this is
after yesterday's round going into
today's round three players were tied at
the top and Sergei azeroth joining them
at the expense unfortunately for El Sean
yesterday this is still just like Group
A this is anybody's chess tournament
here five days for sure I mean look at
look at those standings and I mean yes
there you know two points difference
between the top three and the last three
players but anything can happen there we
still have five rounds to go so I think
we can we can expect for sure some great
chess here at the winter chest classic
no doubt and if you're just joining us
for the first time our tournament format
is as follows we have a game in 94 the
first 40 moves and then there's 30
minutes for the remainder of the game
so once they make time control 30
minutes is added onto each clock there's
a 30 second increment from move number
one so it's hard to lose on time but the
pressure is gonna be staying on if
you're down in time there are no draw
offers to be made or accepted before
blacks thirtieth move to encourage
fighting chess our schedule we're on the
air for another five days we're gonna be
going until Monday the 18th where we'll
start a little bit early now this show
begins two and a half hours after the
start of the actual round you can see
the games before and after we're on the
air at us chess champs calm including
today we invite you to join us on social
media especially in the YouTube chat and
on Twitter and Facebook with hash tag
winter chess classic in the chat so far
well you guys aren't very active yet so
if you have any questions shoot them our
way and we'll have a good discussion
quite potentially ok no more waste of
time let's get a look at our group a
pairings for today here at the winter
chess classic all of the games are still
underway we have Victor Erdos vs. var
Cobian
Daniel Meredith ski versus Sam sabaean
Alexei Serrano vs. Jeffrey Zhang Renaud
Jim abaya
vs. Gregory Oberon and Huff honest
caboose Ian versus Grandmaster sethu
these two had switched colors two years
ago in Abu Dhabi this is a rematch their
second meeting here that game was a draw
let's see where were
and here in our key matchup in group a
this is the current position then that
we're having alright just making sure
I'm in the current position it's always
good to do yeah I was not so yeah so we
chose this game because I thought it was
really interesting a few moves back so
I'd really like to go back to that
moment because I thought it was a really
interesting position over here it moves
18 so in this position that we got from
an English and then kind of looks like a
reversed Benoni for white in this
position white played a 3 in order to
stop Knight coming to b4 probably and
just you know typical plans for for
white are to make sure they play a three
they'll prepare to play some before so a
three is kind of part of the plan but
white probably missed this very
beautiful move I think Knight to d4 just
hanging the knight but actually you
cannot really capture it because if you
do then you might have to face a little
shack rook and it's not going to be very
fun for white so fortunately after this
night to default seems like White's
position starts collapsing so I think it
was the reason why we decided to go for
this game is the key matchup and it
seemed really interesting in both
players we can see them really focused
in this this moment that is a really
crazy night outpost yes is there any way
not right there in the center that is
devastating it's not really because you
know you cannot take it so now you have
to move the Queen but you really do not
want to put it in b2 because if you do
then you know where are you going to
develop this poor bishop in c1 and their
ideas with 92 of course as well so in
the game the bushland chose to go Queen
f2 actually give the b-pawn kind of
playing in in the spirit of a gambit or
if we're thinking reverse colors maybe
like a bank or gambit and just give up
that pawn and try to take
advantage of the you know be file that
opens up try to get you know his rook
and Bishop work together towards b7 but
unfortunately this wasn't enough for him
to actually get his pawn back because
now black can take the knight the bishop
in c1 and even if you have this
intermediate move now you have to
recapture the knight you cannot stay
with the piece down so now your rook was
taken away from the B file and then
black gets to protect the pawn very
important and then the next move
b6 was played creating this chain of
pawns that's going to be very strong
black has the pair of bishops as well so
they maintain a really good position now
it remains to be seen if the tournament
is going to be able to convert this
position I do really enjoy having an
extra pawn on the board for sure so but
we have seen Debussy on coming back from
from difficult positions I think and so
it'll be interesting to see how this
game plans to be I believe I have some
some few more moves since the position
that I had just pointed out so these are
pretty natural most white is trying to
build a little bit of pressure I would
say on the King side as well they had to
go into a2 to make sure they were to
lose even more material but now they're
doubling up on the F file with the
intention of trying to play E for it
might seem like white is trying to open
up the position here Ben but I think
they also want to make sure if this
bishop stays in d5 it might not be so
easy for Y to get their pieces active so
you know with a pawn down we're thinking
trying to create some kind of fortress
over here and now I said to Rahman
retreated with the bishop in g7 trying
to get ready for a potential opening of
the Kings side but this has happened and
then we had a few more moves Queen to b3
protecting this d3 pawn
Bishop Rybak so black has the ability to
kind of switch between those two
attackers and then of course we also
have b5 idea for black trying to
undermine the protection of this bishop
in d5 and this is the current position
that we have black is still deciding
with which piece to capture I think
Bishop should be capturing I still like
blacks position trades should be in his
favor what do you think yeah I mean I'm
not one to question your analysis but I
certainly don't disagree with it okay
yeah
sathru looking in in good shape here and
you know he's near the bottom of the
leaderboard right now and in fact tied
for last yeah so maybe this will be his
chance to get back in the game yes and
change change his fate yesterday he
already had kind of you know helpful
wing I think with his opponent we don't
know for sure yet we haven't had the
chance to interview either one of them
so settlement or victory Erdos but
hopefully we'll have them at some point
come to join us for an interview and ask
them what happened in that game because
just keeps us hanging all this time how
is it possible that you know you're
you're missing you're you're giving up
the Queen with with not apparent
sufficient counter play so and you know
even if we interview them in later
rounds we could bring up games of the
past sure get out the shovel we're
digging up the past you might like it
you might hate it we might do it I mean
I'm not sure the players will be happy
with that sometimes in a tournament
where you start you know bad knee or you
have a really bad game you're thinking
oh I really want to forget about this
let's just forget about the past imagine
we're starting a completely new
tournament the next day and sometimes it
works you know so hopefully we will not
just you know they will not feel
offended if we would bring it up but it
remains to be seen for now it's just a
dream that we have right a dream could
become reality let's take a look at our
B section here at the winter chess
classic we have
a clear leader now in Sergei azeroth
after he had a draw with young Justin
Wang but there are four games still in
progress l Shawn mafia body versus
Sergei Arenberg Christopher you versus
federico perez Ponza alexei Sorokin vs
haru-kun yan emilio Cordova vs. Melek
Kishan is our key matchup this is a
first-time matchup between the Peruvian
Cordova and the US Championship veteran
and renowned trainer McCutcheon let's
take a look at this game in Group B yes
so this is the current position seems I
know crazy what do you I mean a lot of
things have changed since we since I
have lost in this position
Wow we got the part in b7 that seems
about to promote am I missing something
here
yeah that part looks huge right now ah
yeah what is going on here yes this
thing just over where well how long ago
did you look at this game I looked maybe
about 10 minutes 15 minutes ago a little
bit before getting back I mean getting
to be live so if we move a few more
let's go a few moves back because I
believe white was better from the
opening it was a terrace defense and I
usually okay let's just take it from the
beginning take our viewers through what
has happened so on a different move
order we had at Irish defense
okay so g3 is one of the best systems in
my opinion against the the Tarrasch
looks like a catalan as well but just
because of this capture Bishop g2 I
would call it a terrorist hopefully I'm
not wrong here Bank 96 Castle Bishop e7
93 castle and here White has a variety
of options I think this is one of the
most popular ones
Bishop g5 is another option
but do you take c5 basically what you're
trying to do is make black move this
Bishop once again to take the pawn and
then you want to go Bishop g5 pin the
night and indirectly put pressure on the
d5 pawn because now the night is not
technically protecting it anymore so
these are some old lines Kasparov used
to play them so but of course in this
position black is not necessarily forced
to recapture their pawn they can say you
know what I know that I'm going to have
an isolated pawn here in d5 and a very
important rule when you have an isolated
pawn in the center is to try to push it
as much as possible because the more you
push it the more annoying it will be for
your opponent to get rid of the pawn
from there and also you're controlling
some squares in their territory not
letting them you know for example push
this this pawn in e2 and make it simply
harder to blockade and attack so this is
what Malik went for and I think this is
an older line mm-hmm not not to my
knowledge
played as much these days
so Bishop f5 white is finishing
development and you know they do have
the extra pawn but like I said that this
point in the center is strong and also
White has to stay for quite some time
with a snide paint badly placed knight
on the rim not really something damn
yeah exactly it's great not so happy but
you do have the extra pawn so there's
always a trade-off in chess Bishop e4
rook to c1 so now what white is trying
to do just making sure they protect the
pawn very well and then the plan that
actually happened in the game is to make
sure you get to protect that pawn to c5
make it really strong with this
beautiful chain of pawns and then
eventually tonight we'll come back into
play through b2 now if you have the
chance to bring it to c4 or d3 to block
it that
isolated pawn that would be amazing but
anyways so moving on to how the game
continued so around here it was the last
time that I had seen this game rook to
e1 h6 seems pretty pretty typical as you
can see black the way they place their
pieces is very it's very central keeping
the defence over the pawn also with the
Queen and the best show here it's a it's
a really nice combination because you
will not be able to move the knight from
f3 often times you want to improve order
to move the knight so that your Bishop
will get open
but with this pressure here you cannot
really it's not gonna be ideal you don't
want to trade you're feeling kind of
Bishop so yeah I think Black has done a
beautiful placement of the pieces and
now we see white going aggressive b5
chasing the night away and now b6 hmm
what do you think about this man well
it's it's game time for thee okay so he
closed it up you have to close it up I
think I I mean you couldn't take here
because oopsie
there a fork right so I kind of have to
close it up so you would think that this
wasn't such a great idea for white
because now they kind of locate their
past their majority right usually the
way we create the past pawn is pushing
this C pawn and then they take and we
take back and we have our passport but
here Y decided to go for b6 for sure
they they they had a plan to utilize
this pawn much stronger here in b6 with
some idea of at some point pushing c6
forcing black to capture in statistics
and then white would go with that beep
on which is eventually something that we
have in the current position so I think
a few more moves have been made so let's
just move through the game really fast
finally white kind of had to trade
LightSquared bishop but now took black
screen away from the center and of
course with an extra pawn we're super
happy to trade Queens if you were to do
this I think white should have no
trouble winning this position with the
extra pawn and no no kind of contra play
for black but after Queen h3 maybe you
have to make sure you stay more to take
care of your King there are some ideas
94 not too much though I don't really
see how black could try to get rid of
this knight in f3 but that's let's look
Oh unless you move by herself Knight to
e5 okay 94 threatening the mate forcing
the trades of the night and now white is
finally bringing their bad night in a 4
into the game night to be - we should
get closer to the current position
because I think that Melek has just
forgotten about a rook and blundered
badly well it was it was chemistry
that's why I wanted to see what happened
so here's the idea that I mentioned
earlier so white sacrifices this pawn
with the idea to get rid of the
blockading
piece to the past now rook takes oh
we're winning a piece you have to
recapture and now b7 and let's see and
now that this was the position that we
had stepped on and clearly white wants
to take the route back and then they
don't have an extra piece for a pawn ok
extra piece is an extra piece so mmm so
the idea of this route b5 was in case
you capture here and do promote Queen
recaptures and now both your knight and
your Bishop are under attack and you
don't really have a way to protect both
of them so this was probably Malik's
idea but after rook to b5
White's played Wow beautiful move Queen
to e4 and
I think this might be game over and so
we're just attracting the Queen snacking
the White Queen take me and then I'm
gonna promote on c8 yeah we're
distracting the Queen from the
protection of the rook the Queen's have
to trade and now pawn takes c8 promotion
to a queen which I believe was made on
the board by Grandmaster Emilio Cordova
and now King h7 is probably the only
move all right and we have this current
position but white hasn't a piece for a
pawn and so this should be something
it's probably close to close to being
over for Malik I don't really see any
ways to come back with some counter play
here it seems like just a clear piece
down and we see Malik not very
comfortable in this position after 93
tough-talking
he had some really strong some really
beautiful games in the past few rounds
and yesterday he we had him interviewed
Bishop takes any threes was he playing
he was very confident with his play but
he did have three White's out of four
games so now he will have to defend a
few games with black but here it seems
like very tough position it is important
to note actually you kind of in a
roundabout way brought up a good point
this being a 10 player tournament c9
rounder which means that half of the
field is gonna get five White's
half of the field is gonna get by blacks
a slight difference but still an
advantage yes I mean a lot of
grandmasters do say it's it's an
advantage I actually have a student who
recently told me she actually loves
playing with black she prefers to play
with black pieces so I don't know it's
it's interests
but yeah for sure now it based on how
the pairings are made sometimes you
would get you know a lot more white so
at some point you you have to catch up
still you know he's used one of the
lucky ones who gets five points and four
blacks
so yeah but interesting game I think we
should come back to to this game but
fortunately I don't see I don't see much
many ways for for blacks to come back
and this game ban I know Malik is your
friend good friends so it's going to be
well we all have good friends in this
event that is sometimes they're a good
time sometimes there are bad times but
miracles can happen so you know we
especially on the chessboard that is
true yeah your life to hopefully in life
too
let's go and to group a I'd like to see
if I ruin a Kobe ins game as black let's
do that against Victor Josh all right so
this is the current position in Victor L
George against for a cobia all right so
white is a little bit more active at
this rocking c7 but
I think the position is maybe a little
bit better for white because of the rook
and why did have this isolated pawn in
d4 which they managed to push so they're
getting rid of that isolated pawn but
with the rook a little bit more active
than this one in b8 I think white is a
little bit better in this position
would you consider bringing if you were
Victor bringing the King up the board is
it time yet oh no I think it's time yet
to bring the King maybe maybe just to e3
but not you cannot really hmm good point
I'm trying I'm trying to decide if I if
I want to bring the King or I should do
something about you know black not not
trying to get to push these pawns a
little bit more but if you do push them
then you have to be worried a little bit
about the rook attack hmm very it's a
very complex position feels better for
white but it's not so maybe just can you
three yeah maybe maybe I right bring the
kingdom's a bit well I feel like I want
to get both rooks on the seventh rank
and that would be great
well right right it's a dream right but
yeah I feel like the the dirac if I move
that of course now my D pawn is a
liability so how do I deal with that so
that that's what I'm thinking in my 1500
break no no no not at all yeah you're
definitely right you have a good point
it would be amazing for white if they
get the chance to bring you know this
rook there's a play basically play rook
e7 and bring the other up to c7 the only
problem is well there are two problems I
think one as you mentioned losing the
pawn 85 second one if you lose that pawn
in d5 then suddenly blacks should be
able to play Bishop to c6 if they do
that then
your roof will not be able to get on
seventh-ranked anymore so black could
try to defend their extra pawn so you
probably don't want to do that what I
was thinking about is whether we want to
take here or not this is this is a an
idea that does come to mind because you
kind of have to reach recapture with
with the rookie cannot take in do you
want because of course we have this
intermediate move then we captured the
rook and we are going to be winning so
you have to recapture with the rook this
is a position there's trying to to
decide if we want to have this position
and try to go for the pawn here in b7 or
not I would say that we do did we have
some new did we have some more moves no
no moves yet but I'm thinking not King
III but I'm thinking just going for the
pawn seems like the wise thing to do no
extra pawn can we rule this yeah there
you go
can we win this position or not perfect
I don't know if we can win it but I like
it for do we together right I like it
okay okay yeah it's going to be tough to
var had a tough game yesterday and today
he has to defend so I also look at the
times white is about 22 minutes and then
black six minutes so and they're unmoved
25 so they still have 15 moves each
until they get that half an hour at it
onto the clocks yeah so far is not
sweating yet but something he's
definitely aware of you yes and he has
to fight for a draw now for sure just do
it do you have some some moves happening
I
am I not getting the I think it's my
boyfriend
I think can we get in closer to the the
board maybe we could see yes current
position wait Wow
so Varro inferred rook takes do you want
okay I must have missed something here
why we have this intermediate move it's
with check you have to recapture and
then we take I think yeah still an extra
pawn maybe he preferred to have this
position then the other one when he
gives up the b-pawn he might be thinking
this is a little bit better for him
maybe he has some ideas bringing the
rope but let's sink maybe get the board
back here yeah he's just interesting to
see he didn't want viola be friends you
there
what's the be pons name again a lot of
names right they do yeah you know
there's Harry I don't know I don't know
the names I feel bad whoa okay there's
supposed to be news all right we'll
figure it out I only know Harry that's
it in the chat what is the beat bronze
name hit us up what do you say we jump
on over to the B group in the mean time
and look at L Shawn's game sure let's do
that well Shawn versus Sergei Arenberg
yeah alright so there have been some
changes since I unless seen this
position as well I thought white was a
little bit better
earlier Oh Sergei really down on time
here 27 to 90 seconds yeah and I believe
at some point there was about an hour an
hour discrepancy yeah and they have 12
more moves until they hit that move 40
but a lot of things have changed since
I've last seen it I think I last saw the
position around here they just came out
of the opening and white has temporarily
given a pawn but this age 5 pawn is for
sure going to be falling so
that's exactly what has happened so
black one for Bishop d6 offering the
bishop trade because you know they want
to bring their queen back and this
bishop in in effort is really strong
keeping blacks King not too safe I think
so you want to get rid of this attacking
piece a Bishop d6 seems like a normal
move for black to play that would be one
this is a very interesting intermediate
move so you're not going you somehow
have to trade the bishops anyways but
you're thinking where is my rook better
placed is it on the sea fowl or is it on
the B file so else Shawn went Ruby one
intermediate move because now he's
thinking the B file is a better
placement for the rook considering this
chain of ponds has its base in b7 so
you're probably better off attacking b7
so he played this move Queen e3 Bishop
trades seemed inevitable I am I thought
the idea behind rugby one was to try to
pry the black Queen off that diagonal
where wouldn't rook b3 do the trick
right here so you could make the Queen
move and then get that Bishop off of
these six does that work I know I'm
missing something
no no no no I thought that motion should
not work is probably Queen a5 and the
idea being if you take my bishop then
you're going to have to meet this check
home so that's probably the reason why
you kind of don't want to do that
because reason enough for me yeah and
your bishop is hanging and then there's
that yeah no but good good point to show
this because you always want to be
careful of your back rank even if you
have an heir a place to escape with the
king you still want to make sure that
you keep you keep an eye on some route
getting on the first rank and securing
you're creating a fork so that's why in
this position wine had to make the trade
of the bishops I don't think there's any
other good intermediate move and you
definitely don't want to move
special because then black will have
some ideas on your 19 g3 so we have to
trade and now Ellen went for that h5
pawn now equalizing the material and
it's a very interesting position because
you know opposite side castling for both
you have to kind of decide which one of
the Kings is safer for sure it's it's a
little bit annoying for both of them the
fact that they have a rook just putting
pressure on on the pawns close to them
so Queen afore and now black is trying
to get some activity on the default pawn
so white retreats Queen to d1 I believe
that's pretty normal
rook G for a little bit more pressure
hmm you know what actually a little bit
earlier now that I'm looking at the
position a little bit more I feel like
breaking news here Sabina we have
another result in Group E Christopher
you and Federico Perez pawns I have
drawn their game alright so still no
decisive games in beat but that one is
was agreed to a draw at move 30 alright
so in this position I really like
getting this title to be better maybe
maybe Knight a5 was a move that that
white could have played to avoid
allowing the bishops to be traded maybe
that would have been a slightly better
move because now I'm really not sure how
the knight can get to be improved so
rook to g4 and now I'm sure is going for
the H pawn just forward saying you know
what I don't care feel free to take my
pawn but I don't think it's going to be
too helpful for you first of all you're
going to lose something look at this
beautiful idea attacking the rook but
now also looking at this fork so you
cannot capture the pawn even if that
might have been your idea so black is
going to rotate trying to make sure the
H pawn will not go too much forward
Queen
3:96 a for looking for an idea to play
85 and try to get to p7 and now Luke g7
protecting the seventh rank so I believe
we have had a few more moves here alchun
played Queen to d3 and black responded
by playing Knight to c4 improving the
position of the night what do you think
about this position Ben what are your
your thoughts about the position I I
don't want to try I'm trying not to be
too you know imbalance here I just want
to make sure everybody is optimistic
view or I don't know it's got well okay
so to me I mean it looks like and for
those of you who are not actually aware
of full disclosure Sabina and L Sean are
an item it's well known in the chess
world and so this has got to be
difficult being in this position for
sure versus personal I know this has
never happened to us before that you
know one of us we've had to do
commentaries on the other ones games I
mean of course we always watching them
intensely and you know and one of us is
playing I know for sure the other one is
not really doing much because you're
always just watching play this or you're
just trying to keep it at home like
everyone else is doing probably for
their favorite players but who's the
more intense chess player URL shown
probably me know I would say to me yeah
if I lose a game it's pretty tough
it's uh I get very mad I I get very
emotional and I'm not just just get the
men of myself obviously but sometimes
you know I just from my talks
it could affect health sharing a little
bit I try my best not to but you know
when you're mad you're not really
thinking about other people's feelings
as much so does it help having the other
one around for emotional support at all
during tournaments I certainly hope so
well we're about to find out hey you
guys in the chat had some good pawn
names here for real stupid that's his
real name I'm sure said that the names
are Airy Barry Cedric Derek
Eddie Freddie Gary and of course our
favorite Harry thank you very much I
read his aloud because he gave us the
whole family all right I didn't know
that so okay I should take a note of
that that that's always good to teach to
use as a material to teach I'm sure I'm
sure like the names were published in a
book something impulsive the real I'm
sure I'm sure
I just you know let's take a look at
some of the other games do you have a
very specific one in mind that you might
want to go over can we check in just
because of who they are I haven't seen
the game at all of course Daniel
narrowed its key and Samsa beyond end
group oh that's that's for sure going to
be a very exciting game cuz both young
players very talented both players grew
up here basically like we didn't I mean
not here in st. Louis but grew up around
the st. Louis chess club this is Sam 7
the first time we saw him was a 2013 US
Championship I believe an era disc II
played in the first Junior Championships
here at the club so we've definitely
followed their progress all along the
way oh we have a results and it looks
like Melek may have fallen to Cordova so
maybe we will try to see if we can get
Cordova down here yeah for an interview
if she's willing to that would be no be
interesting since we haven't had him
interview yet
definitely a tough tough day for Melek
yesterday and now emilio joins a whole
slew of players in Group B that have
tons of they all have three points so no
I said slow SSL II W Emilio's actually
at Webster University yeah that's why
yeah slew versus slew in st. Louis
University is
a slew here in the metro area so no he
goes to Webster University mm-hmm where
they also of course have but you know
the best team in all of chess at the
college level so much storied history
there okay so now we see narrowed Itsuki
and Sam Semyon narrow disc II has the
best facial expressions and he it's like
he knows when he's in the corner because
he always makes sure we can see his face
are you sure I swear every time all the
US Junior Championships he could be in
the corner and the camera mounted on the
ceiling can't see his head he'll turn
his head around like an owl there has to
be a face like that he's clearly in deep
thought so is Sam and I believe it's
actually Daniels move after looks to see
six played by Sam seven so hmm
this position is very interesting I feel
like we might get to a draw yes it looks
like that it looks like that well let's
keep the analysis rollin Emilio Cordova
is rave coming here we won't say he's
from Slough I never did okay Webster
University zone and I'll be back in just
a bit sounds good so when we get as we
get Emilio Cordova set up let's just try
to think about actually I have my I have
come across another very interesting
position that we haven't really gone
through Grandmaster Alexa run against
Jeffrey Zhang very interesting end game
will black be able to win this position
that is the question it's going to be
tough I think probably and white in this
position should try to bring their king
maybe to g5 get some g4 going and try to
make sure that once they get to g6 pawn
that they are going to be as fast as
blacks deep on but that remains to be
seen we have Emilio Cordova thanks for
joining us
Congrats I was a nice game today yeah at
least he was not like the second game
that I play okay yeah what happened in
that game the game that you played
against you yeah it was like my idea was
to play Queen at 5:00 and suddenly I
just played through the fire I just
might just by mistake you were just yeah
yeah I was like a 5 in takes be sure the
first it was like a kind of accidental
permit but I don't know sometimes it's
happening to me so yeah for the gang of
today I think I was kind of lucky I
think because the position was so
complicated and he just tried to I don't
know once he tried to play something I
really - get more pieces then he was
like I thought that I have enough
control chancer for the Queen side
because the point of the six is so
strong yeah so at least I thought that
maybe in the against I could have some
good chances I know for sure that black
has a lot of compensation but I wasn't
so sure mm-hmm
so yeah and then yes for sure he
plundered this Queen yeah that was a
very beautiful move Queen Queen to b4
yeah actually as position what I didn't
calculate this I mean once he hit play
Knight takes c6 I say okay maybe I miss
something but my intuition tells me that
something looks okay because all my
pieces are well placed but it seems
difficult from here for black to to try
to save themselves already in this
position I think it's maybe some 96 at
some point is that effective earlier
yeah because I think this route effect
was kind of optimistic mm-hm
but okay it's up on down maybe I can try
here that was a probably thinking that I
was expecting black was supposed to from
the opening I think black was supposed
to somehow get some counter play didn't
seem as much for black he seemed like he
had really good placement of the pieces
yeah yeah you didn't get his material
back yeah I know that the black needs to
do something tree fast but I couldn't
figure out what to do I don't usually
it's something on the e pawn just put a
lot of pressure but he puts his rooks on
yeah
and c8 so I thought usually try to put
on the epon but it's been a really long
time since I played these yeah I don't
like to play this as wife yeah I think
that way I have a lot of conferences but
I don't know I mean I think it's not
that okay maybe it's I know for sure the
blood she was so actually I was thinking
after before Roxy a my first idea was to
play with h3 so but then I was a scary
of Queen h5 actually know or Sundy three
yeah no no sorry yeah after rook e1
after oqi so yeah okay h6 so now be sure
the age three was my first idea but then
I saw something like on each wife and I
was so scary I mean I was so afraid of
this move because CA 28 sine hundred
ninety five and yeah yeah and I thought
that he was so hard to move that they
showed only for my night only only for
looks so bad I might be shot on the
floor looks weird to so I don't know
maybe this is wrong let me computer will
agree that white is winning here but I
don't know further we have no check the
computer which right which right to stay
away from the computer
yeah like possible did he was too
complicated here too
I mean maybe g5g fire chief or also yeah
ideas could be right so does it that it
was so simple to play as black and I
have to I need to find here tree good
move mm-hm
and I don't know I I don't like to be
like I don't like to take pieces for
yeah but I prefer to keep impotent yeah
yeah of course yeah usually when your
opponent gives up on an exchange and
they have some attack it can get very
annoying yeah a lot of players and the
bishop on the phone is so powerful so I
was wondering how I can remove that
vision yeah so usually I think you just
go Bishop f1 and try to go 92 but I
don't but there was a first time yes
really from these three yeah that's why
I play rookie one because in some
variation that he was some fun takes
money to so my rook on you're not my
queen only one was on the return so
that's why I play rook e1 my idea was to
try to play some history
point mm-hmm yeah but you probably
should you block this one before you do
it because I have nice history so that's
the difference
okay yeah so that was kind of a trick
that's true yeah so here I don't know I
thought that'd be fine was okay at least
just to push the pause and not to get
worse
yeah and this Mystics idea is very
interesting you often want to play c6
but but here you probably had envisioned
that you'll go Bishop c7 and do you have
this kind of idea with with c6 and yeah
so I should yeah I was expecting maybe
three
yeah I thought Ruby's d7 is kind of a
normal movie not like with the flow of
the position so that was my feeling and
everything I have to say I was thinking
on Ruby one actually just get rid of the
bishop yes yeah so be sure a screen
takes and then I don't know because
there is some 95 threats yeah if he goes
here from your naughty five fun this
looks so beautiful
mhm I don't know I I felt that I have to
play more dynamic so that well this odd
you have this discovery now which is
very yeah yeah I thought that that that
we should is so powerful that night I
just want to remove that vision so what
if I don't take the rock what if I take
in see yes so that was the heart okay so
what about it just keeps I was thinking
something like rook before maybe at some
point and then to take on a4 and d4 is
under attack
96 yeah it's probably you probably
should take the exchange yes I wasn't so
sure about this position but do you have
the exchange after all like yeah but the
hard to hard it's hard yeah yeah wait
wait there's this kind of very annoying
idea so maybe I don't know I I wasn't so
optimistic with this position I think
because at the beginning my idea was be
sure they stay and I should be okay but
then i saw this pin h5 and I started to
get a surprising to you yeah it was a
surprise for me I mean this is from the
human perspective looks like okay but I
mean blacks cannot make this type of
move I think because
not the type of position that you should
yeah especially because this c6 just
comes with temple
yes maybe maybe put it somewhere else
maybe there I thought that 93 probably
was the right options in that position
it just seems like it's going it's going
in in your favor from here oh yeah
because it's also move for natural so
I'm trading some pieces which mean is
good yeah yeah yeah that's what I
thought I we're doing commentary a
little bit around this this time and
then we thought okay this should be
great for you cuz you know just yeah
looks like that yeah after that after
the beautiful beautiful more sacrifice
and then yeah probably here you have to
play something that rook afaid I thought
would you try to promote yes because so
I have to play nicely for first will be
five and groupie one that's what I was
calculated so I thought this should be
winning I guess I don't know maybe not
but I couldn't find a good move for
black so should be good for me yes
because I hope the eight is not a move
Queen d7 is an option but then just
promote yeah because the other variation
was probably one ping b1 and Queen takes
e 2 and then B 8 so I was kind of a
scary of the pawn for sure
rook takes Queen takes King h8 sorry is
h7 and now Queen b3
that was the move that I went that I
miss actually my calculation but then I
found this and I say okay it's okay so
this now you can go Bishop f4 me yeah we
should the for Bishop a5 but most are
okay stopping Department yeah and I was
so happy that I could find this much so
yeah I knew that
okay maybe what to still have some no
tricks but yeah but I mean it's a piece
yes you should be able Bishop if I
doesn't really matter because on f4 and
gh4 and all the scores are under control
so I thought that it was good yeah but
in the openings you're probably blood
has many
but I couldn't remember the good thing
is my memory so bad that I knew that
this was a good for black with a lot of
translation but it was not so sure how
good it was okay maybe and if I can
convert it this way I mean you have to
try I think in general if you don't know
what if you don't remember a line
usually should try to yes like some
natural moves make sure yeah you're not
wondering and then you kind of escape
from the opponent's preparation yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah actually that was my
whole idea just to not go under in one
move yeah because it was so painful and
yeah but it's okay yeah I think I was
kind of lucky here because I mean I
thought that maybe he has some
interesting ideas but then yeah but he
couldn't find out during the game -
because it's like black need to be very
precise and whites just need to make a
natural move like rookie see one rookie
one okay and the worst scenario probably
is like okay I will lose my pawn okay
drop yeah so I think but I don't know
maybe this is this is so good for black
I don't know yeah I I I prefer white the
way you played it but of course you know
it remains to be double-checked yeah I
think that it was only five five years
be five at some point instead of some we
should take five but I don't remember so
well actually my memory so bad
so we should have forty 2014 how this
position looks like good but I don't
know if black needs to play some d5 at
some point in the opening afterwards
around here maybe yeah yeah create some
country chance yeah I mean it feels like
okay maybe what should be okay but I
have to get your knight back into place
yeah and it's very simple I think
because with addition and therefore this
looks so good for black so I mean
probably
there is nothing but I feel like this
should be the like the other option so
yeah you know was lucky that I found
this creamy form of because I didn't
calculate but yeah that's beautiful yeah
it's very sacrificing then you get -
well that's sacrifice but
yeah yeah yeah thinking a queen is
always nice when it works so now you are
in the United States are you studying
yeah yeah at Western University when
when did you start studying like two
years ago yeah it's good
I know it's kind of hard to deal with
the chest and studies there's a reason
that one my rating is so low now but
yeah I think it's a great opportunity to
learn another language to study
something to learn some new things it's
good and yeah I mean it's another good
opportunity another way to see lifestyle
that's happy too yeah we're here we're
happy to have you here at the tournament
and I am an immigrant myself I came as a
student with a scholarship in the United
States so I find it to be a great
opportunity so hopefully you're enjoying
it and you're going to benefit both your
life in general and chess
yeah yeah yeah don't forget about chess
we yeah I'm trying and trying to know
the blunderin anymore Lisa I hoped in
the blunder it happens yeah yeah yeah so
thank you so much thank you for for
joining us here and we should good luck
for the remaining of the runs and hope
we'll see you again here thank you thank
you all right that was Grandmaster
Emilio Cordova taking us through his
game let's see if if there were any
other results so before we got into the
interview I was looking at this very
interesting end game that was played
between grandmaster alexei Serena and
Jeffrey Zhang and this was the position
that we had where well there are a few
more moves both I guess
both players rich move 40 and they got
the additional time so nice it's the
right moment for white to calculate all
the lines and try to see if they have
any ways to save the
position it's going to be a little bit
tough of course it'll be ideal to get
rid of these we have these pawns that
would be amazing if you can just trade
them off get our King in front of the
pawn and get to fill their position draw
but you know everything has to happen
according to the rules of chess which
you know every player has to make them
off by just one so I'm wondering if we
will be talking to Jeffrey Jean yet
again today let's see the only two-time
seasonal Classic champion in chess club
history he's a big deal a young man from
Coppell Texas is amongst he's breaking
into the worlds at leaf okay I mean this
is a big deal we're gonna be talking
about Jeffrey Zhang at the top of the
game for years to come and it's really
excited to see him at this point
soon I believe we just had a move by an
Alexis arena G takes age five so he's
trying to go for this train and I'm
trying to think if Brooke g5 would be
the right move here for white or and I
don't believe we had mentioned it but
Daniel Meredydd Sookie and Sam seven
have drawn their game oh okay
and so this puts Sam at the top of the
leaderboard live in Group A I wonder if
we can have one of them joining us for
an interview I do not believe either one
I mean I know neither one of them have
joined us yeah not yet so we'll see
without yeah we'll see if we can get
either Daniel or Sam in for an interview
how about we let's look at a game we
haven't seen yet that's yeah
the leader coming in today renown Juma
by of against Gregory Opera in from
Russia this is the current position so
White has the pair of Bishops and the
majority on the Queen side on the Kings
side and Black has the majority on the
Queen side I prefer white in this
position because of the pair of bishops
and white after this last move rook to
d1 will be preparing eventually to start
pushing the pawns chasing this night
away black is kind of stuck protecting
this pawn for the moment they might try
some Bishop before maybe it's not really
it's not so simple for black in this
position both players are really below 5
minutes now and they have to make
another 5 moves that's not so much you
know a minute per move but the position
is not really ideal for for black I
think
Bishop b4 was just played ok so I was
right about one move that's good
but um-hmm I feel like now okay you're
trading the pair of Bishops is black but
they're still trading a bishop that
wasn't yet ready to come into the game
so why should be happy with the trade
I went probably I was think maybe Bishop
takes b4 followed by e4 would be
something that we could see in this
position and I'm anticipating a nice
capture and before although maybe pawn
capturing could be an idea too and then
even if you get the double pawns then
you have this kind of interesting idea
c5 c4 and then trying to get this rook
you need to open up what's your
impression about this
yes yeah I mean I agree with that
I also appreciate your vast knowledge of
the different colored arrows but yeah I
agree with your assessment here it's
looking like this game and yeah I would
give a slight edge to white writing a
lot of these games today are looking
pretty equal and so with these
tournaments it's that's a little unusual
because when we have the 2500 level
players the 2600 level players it's not
like the world elite players where every
game is a draw
Allah the Sinquefield Cup 2017 2018 so
it's a it's an exciting day hey you've
got to earn the half point you still
gotta earn it
of course and you need to make your
thirty moves before he can even dare to
offer a draw if you are planning to do
so so yeah that's just did we just see a
trade I believe we just saw training
before all right I feel good today feel
like I'm guessing someone you're the
predictor I feel like I'm not always
predicting very well okay so we did see
a night capture not upon capture as I
was pointing out with all those errors
Ben they were not getting my my thoughts
and and actually because you mentioned
of I have colors of arrows I think it's
really cool and you're teaching and if
you're explaining something to use
different kind of arrows as long as you
try to use them for the same purposes
always so like if you're gonna talk
about a weakness try to stick to one
color yeah maybe we just read for that
yeah but I don't thought let's do that
cuz it's not as easy you have to change
them
I think we should go and look back at
Serrano Zhang again
a the summers ponds have been exchanged
away and this endgame is simpler now and
it looks like it's in favor of Jeffrey
it is and there's not a way to stop this
in my opinion I mean do you have a
different assessment no this disposition
should should be in blacks should go in
blacks favor the only thing that I was
thinking about if it would work is if
why I was playing to g5 was trying to
figure out if the skin opponent game was
winning or not but it should be it
should be winning for black this pawn is
advanced is advanced enough so like for
example if you were to play h4 here just
King a5 and the King just enters grabs
the pawn and we have sufficient time to
get out from in front of the pawn and
just March it up the board while White's
King will have to go for that one so
this is clearly winning and then if you
don't push the pawn and try to go for
King III I think this oh I just think
very well how much I'm pushing the pawn
forward sometimes you push it too much
and then you realize oh no it was it was
not good because you know white needs to
spend a lot of time to go grab the pawn
and then make it back to f1 that's
basically the whole idea so the more you
push the pawn forward the King will only
less time to get to f1 so but this would
be winning I think maybe h4 should just
sell the deal because if you're talking
to you three and we just go there you
know I don't know that I mentioned this
yet but this is a big game I mean these
two these are the top two seeds in Group
A right here mm-hmm
and Geoffrey looks like he's gonna pull
this one out but I don't know that the
resignation would come anytime soon I
mean they both made time control this
could be something that they really sit
and have a good think about for awhile I
think so because it's a rope endgame and
a lot of routine games can end up in a
draw so you always have to try to find
the best way to hold on to the position
more and also make sure that your
opponent
knows the theoretical positions I mean
it is hard to believe that at their
level they would not know it so they
should know these learn these as kids
and we still see top-level grandmasters
blunder in broken games and theoretical
ones but I think mostly we see that in
blades because they don't have
sufficient time to really know refresh
their memories with the positions but
here both players have plenty of time to
think about it and I think we should we
should for sure see some of their best
chests in Indies and games so alex is
around I just played h4 actually in this
position and this is the current
position that we have so you clearly saw
ok I cannot go for the four that King
opponent game I need to wait a little
bit see what you are going to do but mmm
rookie four might be might be something
oh I saw a nice idea rookie four he's
probably thinking Sabina let's jump over
to a group be really quick because one
of the games we're looking at has ended
in a draw
we have Alexia Sorokin from Texas Tech
versus Tigre and harutunian
they have drawn their game in Group B
and so now we know that harutunian
stands at two and a half points and
Sorokin is live at the top of the
leaderboard with three and a half out of
five okay so what how did we get here in
this game because I did I didn't want to
take a look at it right before yeah I do
not believe we were looking shall we
take it from the beginning or just a few
moves back yes do you think that's what
yeah let's let's go from the beginning
let's see how we got here
a bit so we had groom felled see takes
d5 90s the fact is a lot of theory in
these positions analyzed a lot and I
believe a lot of people say that if you
are playing with white against the broom
fell there are some lies with which you
can for sure make a draw pretty much any
time that you want but is that true or
not remains to be seen
although this game did prove us that I
can make a draw so looks you want so the
whole idea here is basically white needs
to escape really really fast from the
diagonal because black is going to be
putting a lot of pressure on d4 and try
to open up the bishop so they are not
rushing to capture this pawn in in d4
not immediately at least they keep the
pressure and keeping you also with this
pawn to c3 just kind of bothering you
not letting you open up the file so this
is the best placement for the rook just
keeping everything kind of protected
ninety seven okay again this is still
very standard and E 5 now yeah so I'm
not sure if I'm super familiar with this
idea usually I've seen a lot of people
go for Bishop to g4 trying to put
indirectly pressure on d4 by getting rid
of this 19 f3 but this might be a new
trend 'if I've and now white goes for
the space so we have some kind of you
know a switch from girl felt to a king's
Indian style position 9 f6 and white
strengths and strengthens their Center
and they say you know what I'm pretty
happy if you want to trade the Queen's I
think the endgame I'm going to be much
better plus you have some weaknesses
some very big weaknesses you have to be
super careful for so if you're going to
trade the Queen's one of those pawns
could fold very soon so you need to go
for Queen c7 avoid the trade and now
white finishes their development 94
and the next couple of moves seem pretty
natural white gives up their dark square
bishop I mean you really want to avoid
you know sorry you really want to avoid
getting your bishop back here in g3 of
the big completely restricted so you're
better off playing h3 and making that
trade happen pawn takes Bishop takes g4
and 9 9 2 h2 all right so white is
saying go away Bishop and I'm going to
recapture my pawn in g5 the next move
and here white should be playing I think
something I would try what do you think
about f4 idea some g3 and a4 idea I'm
not sure oh yeah
if you move the rook for sure I have
this idea happening but black went for
Bishop f6 hmm so we repeated the
position once and it looks like black
was playing for a win here he could have
continued repeating the position right
because the Queen is trapped you have no
place to to retreat other than go back
there unless you want to sacrifice it
for 2 pieces which I'm sure you probably
don't so we could have gone for this
this draw in this position but clearly
seems that Grandmaster hurry to nians
thought he was better here I guess your
rhetorical question from earlier
I do like f4 because the to me I still
feel safe because the C pawn the black C
pawn on the fifth rank is is blocking
everything all fine and dandy with me
mm-hmm
no it's not usually what you want to do
always because you're helping this
bishop open up but they just feel like
you should try to push all the central
pawns right if there would be a trade
then we would have like three pawns over
here and try to support each other and
just push them and sometimes I'm too
aggressive but also I'm just doing
commentary it's nothing to do that
so rook f7 Bishop to e2 all right so now
he's going back to chase the Queen away
and going for the attack so he thinks
White's King side is a little bit weak
and you should be the one attacking very
interesting okay clearly I need more
study in this position because I would
have comfort at four so yeah the next
move all right so I wonder if this was a
Miss or probably not a Miss just give up
the H pawn black gave up th pawn in
order to have the ability to open the H
file and try to come for some you know
attacks Queen to d8 I wonder your black
jacket black have just blundered that
pawn like no I don't think so
she moves earlier maybe just by playing
h5 they might have not seen this move
Bishop takes g6 now suddenly widest two
pawns up what's happening Bishop g5 so
why is sacrificing the exchange for
those two pawns okay so clearly they
either calculated all of these things or
they were lucky it's either one or the
other
first of all like it's the white one to
get these two pawns right but then black
is coming for this very annoying idea so
okay there's Tobler and master so I
would say probably they calculated all
of this I miss this nice idea with Queen
d8 so Bishop g5 and now all right so now
White has two pawns for the exchange
so black needs to try to take advantage
of the open files when you have an
exchange app you need open files and to
start bringing your rooks into action
you need to make sure they do something
otherwise the extra the rook will really
not help you in any way because like
it's not gonna make a difference if you
have a recorder if you have a
it's gonna be exactly the same if you
don't try to get an active so this is
what black is trying to do bringing the
Queen first and supposedly getting ready
to bring the other of into action Bishop
f5 only move to save the bishop and now
white cannot really afford
I think trading here trading the Queen's
because after rook a fade they will lose
this pawn g4 is not really protecting it
because your paint so the white had to
go for the pawn capturing and now he
still has some ideas in mind getting
this Knight into play and you probably
will never be able to take a five
because we will have some fork over here
tonight
chasing the Queen away now of course
once again you cannot just take this
we're falling for some tactical motifs
all over the place Queen g7 only move
and f6 it's a very nice nice idea by
white I wonder how far ahead they
calculated to get into this this
position I is the first time I'm seeing
the the past 20 moves I have not seen
them because we're doing commentary but
clearly this game requires more spending
more time on and make sure you you
understand what kind of sacrifices were
happening here and trades so now we're
threatening Knights of six once again so
you have to take the pawn and you should
think that in this position black would
be happy because you know now they have
white has only one point for the
exchange but won't they have this
looking one putting more pressure
now you cannot really can you take then
you got pin city right that's what I was
thinking but we do have miss Roffe there
you go it's unclear probably black did
not like to go for disposition because
didn't think how they might be able to
get their rope active though this seems
I'm not sure which color I prefer this
did not happen this did not happen so
why just played rook to e4 left at pawn
there and saying you know what I don't
want to to take the pawn and actually
let black a little bit active so he kept
the pawn there and now he's improving
the position of his King and now he
brings the knight - H - probably with eg
an eye to f3 and going to take it a
little bit later try some eye force
maybe but now after King of 6 this is
how the two players decided to repeat
the position and they have decided on a
draw here very interesting game I feel
like we had only one decisive result in
the B group right the remaining of the
games were I feel like we only had one
decisive results at all it's alright
actually there's more game still going
in Group A and only L shot and Sergey
Aaron Berger played in group how is that
let's check it out going it's very
interesting I'm kind of nervous to watch
it but alright so they did make the time
control and we have a rookin game White
has to passed pawns and so does black
just that blacks passed pawns are
doubled this pawn should fold look right
there
Sabina you would know know he's that a
good luck or bad luck oh he's probably
not very happy I think he was better in
the game
I think it was better in the games
probably trying to think where he messed
up in this position I I don't think I
should have trouble making a draw but
you know if you can try to go for a win
what do you think then well my I'm
looking where you're highlighted that
anyone I want to get rid of that as soon
as possible it's not really necessary in
a way because that pawn is going to be
that pawn is going to be captured pretty
much anytime soon but not sure king g5
may be here for white I'm thinking with
the idea to just chase that look away
and then I'll go for the poem later I
also need to make sure I'm protecting
this point twice before I'm going for
the default because you know I don't
want to give up my h1 which is the most
advanced pawn in this position you
should never give up your most advanced
pawn if it's a passed pawn in my opinion
I don't know what would be blacks but in
Black's case it's a lost cause for their
most advanced ball yes yes so King g5
lists necessary just think a little bit
in this position Ben what do you think
you know black coud answer here sticking
to g5
I'm thinking I'm thinking Kings c5
let's bring the King around no no really
no I want to take care oh sorry I should
that's our good yeah don't listen to me
so you need to move the rook somewhere
or bring the King to protect it right
okay well then just rookie c6 yeah I
just want to uh
so push this one
jeez I think that after f5 white should
have some big chances and came to g5 so
Luke f7 is another option or bringing
the king to protect the rook but I feel
like this should not be good for a blank
this should okay I'm all for both on the
seventh rank let's just have protect
each other and then bring the King
around town c5 great idea right this is
what I'm thinking for black maybe and
the idea would be checking and then just
grabbing the pawn if you all right so he
did play King g5 in this position this
is the current position we have on the
board and he did he does still have a
little bit extra time compared to his
opponent but for sure I mean Sergei
should feel a little bit you know better
in this position considering that you
know he was really long time like one
minute to to make 15 moves or something
I don't know what that was but I think
we had something like that going on and
do you have any other game that you
might want yes big news yes a game in
Group A maybe about and it's our key
matchup taboos Ian versus sethu and it
looks like sethu is in the driver's seat
and he's got mate imminently this thing
should be over in just a moment alright
so what the game this was and the blue
team does not seem very happy Seth seems
pretty confident in this position you're
just looking at the screen you know the
video that we have of them thinking
about this position yes certainly a
tough tough day for gaboon he had a
really great start of the tournament
with
nice wing over one of you know send
those favors I think vara Cobian and
since then he hasn't been doing as good
I mean he's still two points I think but
he lost the game and then yesterday he
saved an interesting end game against
Sam seven and now yeah Saturday's shake
actually I don't worry we're cutting it
close here but we're gonna actually try
to get set through down here in the
studio for an interview having had the
chance to talk to him yet and this is a
big win for him in our key matchup today
very interesting game alright so I'm
glad that I yeah we decided to go for
that match for the key matchup you you
pick them well and you've been picking
on the basis not just of like the the
standings but yeah in terms of like how
interesting the game is which is a fun
thing yeah I think this is the great
thing when you're starting to do the
commentary a little bit later after the
round has started you kind of have an
idea what might happen in the games you
can see already who whose might have a
better position so I try my best to
actually had our friend change no wait
did he change the matchup or maybe that
was yeah we did we didn't have to change
the matchup today for today for this ya
know there was another peak and I was
like no let's go for this game so I
think that making everyone do a little
bit more work can we go back in the end
to John's game with cerana they're still
playing the end game this seems very
very difficult for for way to defend so
I guess if we go back a few moves okay
let's just go back we were around here
why just played h4 and I was trying to
figure out how black would go grab this
H pawn but it looks like Geoffrey didn't
quite go to get the pawn yet it is very
nice idea rookie three check all right
we're gonna get Seth to in here for the
interview he is ready
good all right so I'll be sure to
discuss this game a little bit longer as
we're getting set to Ramon joining us
for an interview so in this position so
he checked the King first making sure
the king would go further away now
rookie four actually much nicer idea
than what I suggested and now Luke 287
the similar idea trying to go for the
skewer but Shack king g3 and now rook to
f5 so black has managed to cut wise King
off from the deep on and now they're
trying to just go forward through the
pawn and you know with the pawns with
the the H pawn or without it we can
certainly say that black should be
clearly winning because White's rook is
on the short side and we have several
money here with us today congratulations
very nice
nice game you had two interesting games
the past two days yeah I mean I started
with zero but three it was completely it
was it was kind of tough but then came
back do you know what we were really
interested in what happened in your game
yesterday was wondering the Queen or was
that something he had was kind of yet to
sacrifice his Queen to get some counter
play mm-hmm but probably he didn't see
this queen of four yeah still it was
very interesting that a lot of
interesting variations which should be
analyzed after the game yeah
yeah we thought it was very nice and
interesting we thought maybe he
blundered I don't know if there was we
didn't we're trying to avoid analyzing
with computers so we we didn't check
exactly what the engine was saying but
it seemed like maybe there were some
other options and he had just assumed
was like he had blundered it but yeah he
missed quite a foreign Queen f4 still I
think the Queen sacrifice was the only
way to get some counter play otherwise
it was even it was for him so even for
the most practical choice here okay
and today were you were you ready for
some did you how did you feel before
going into the round today yeah I mean
my fourth game so science or at least I
didn't I mean I kind of recovered so I
had I was in good spirits but yeah I was
winning in several ways probably I
messed it up a bit but then I found this
nice trick in the end of a sharp-edged
tree okay but in the in the opening was
already prepared I think I was
freestyling basically so you did I don't
know if is before if he four is the best
just faster and trying to put me under
pressure
yeah I think it was clearly better here
and if you if you're more comfortable
you can it's up there to everyone
everyone hurry feel more comfortable so
Bishop Bishop age five and we really
liked your you know tonight 2d for its
takes takes and yeah yeah if he takes
then Queen d4 check yeah he has no way
yeah he has no way to trap your queen
yeah like cuz you have to do one square
yeah like I always have you followed
also you should be to quindi one yeah so
after 94 if he goes for Queen B 2 then I
have check on e4 yeah it's just question
92 check 92 chicken ready for King at 24
okay I wasn't sure I knew you'd give
check I wasn't sure the exact
continuation but like the Mystics is
just I think it's yeah because usually
when you're playing with with black
you're you're playing the banana you're
trying to play III well these six and
take faster but in this case you know
I'm opening like generally it comes
but in this game and so the game here to
give the piece yeah yeah and yeah and
here like is he probably tried some
fortress was trying to play if or do you
think that was
those something good that he did here
really for is that yeah I think it is my
choice otherwise I just a blaze my
position and come and be fire yeah but
what about taking in their five doesn't
seem like it's the right the right thing
about this I've been getting a four kind
of maybe I could even a player for
immediately I should have instead of you
should have six yeah we should be sunny
I have four takes takes and simply it's
winning probably look a for Bishop b4
chicken
also have been even instruction before
maybe even something else yeah chief I
mean yeah it seems like you're doing
great and now the queen is on the other
side of you can't come fast but yeah
yeah and then we we kind of left off
your game around here yeah I mean
interesting but the trades should be in
your favor at some point like yeah yeah
yeah after might have three bishop is
just King after I should just fix a
fight I should not give us give me any
counter play kind of in the game of the
g5 if I let him give a lot of corner
player I mean did you want to play a 5
yourself yeah yeah
I mean I'm just I cannot most night
economic most Queen everything is tied
down and I just come chief edgy food and
I don't see that's true yeah also I have
e4 sometimes I mean so many options but
Apogee if I think if I already but it
doesn't seem so natural I think for a
human to play the day five because you
might still think okay I think yeah
you're it kind of he has got some
activity yeah I know Bishop Queen d6
yeah it was my 40th Moorhead like one
minute I didn't know so I just that
should help you if there yeah yeah so
just get rid of the Queen's you know and
then you just try to regroup maybe a
little bit and then you second I thought
Mischa pitched three was winning but
then out of the blue I mean like a basic
English 3 wait wait at night you managed
to push it yeah no way to stop the pawn
yeah no I just don't Department oh
that's that's beautiful that's nobody
can take with the King on play 94 yeah
so quit be Sun Bishop e7 a 494 just
catch it I saw the same trick with if he
takes like 90 fine stuff 95 for instance
mm-hm
so here I can't do this because the
night is well that's that's nice I mean
I wouldn't think of something like that
too
like the famous game of topple over yeah
very beautiful very beautiful idea but
the death didn't work yeah it might have
supposed mistake I think probably you
should go queen bee ate a quinny-quinn
be it was accurate it's right to take
like a fried egg or d3 Bishop d3 then
from 96 I was thinking about this queen
of six I tried to do the same thing and
you don't have a mate
no I'm not H were looking at I'm a queen
of cooking each one yeah yeah and yeah
he faced an evil is the problem yeah and
the bishop so that's that's not so easy
right yeah yeah yeah Quinn bit was kind
of tricky
okay maybe like Bishop d3 maybe 96 Queen
f6 was thinking about yeah edge for
Bishop fi something like this
I don't have faith in Jesus on but I was
not at all sure you need to you give up
a piece here you have yeah so maybe
maybe there is something yeah yeah I
don't know yes best chance probably it's
not even better for me yeah yeah but it
feels a little bit yeah he probably got
scared of the maid but unfortunately
after this there's yeah Queen of six was
nicer because if I play Bishop g6 then
98 was just say seven we should be so
nice nice again 1994 and 26 is coming 95
26 it is possible
yeah this despawn proved to be actually
was very nice yeah coming here - look we
need [ __ ] is coming and that's tricking
him yeah
well very very awesome game we're
thankful that you came - to share it
with us and share your thoughts about
the game it's nice to see you back into
the game do you know to come back after
after three tough losses yeah yeah and
then I came back so maybe maybe this is
something that's happening to you but
other than that you enjoy being here in
the place and have been here last year
so I pretty much like the conditions and
and I thank mr. Tony for inviting me
again yeah great we'll be sure to let
him know Thanks thanks so much for
joining us and we'll we wish you good
luck for the remaining of the rounds and
we'll see you hopefully again your son
yep thank you alright so we have or so
we're thankful for cetera man for
joining us for an interview and we have
a result we have had a result as the
interview was going on
Jeffery's shank won his game so as I
predicted a little bit earlier it seemed
impossible to stop the deep on and I
think Geoffrey is going to be so later
possibly if I have the standings right
Ben is going to be joining me in just a
second I'm here you are right Geoffrey
Zhong is the sole leader all right we'll
be taking a look at the the standings
here in just a moment when we have them
but I want to
talk about the upcoming events starting
in just eight days grande chest or the
final event in regulation and for the
first time it's in India it's in Kolkata
and we're going to have a rapid and
blitz attack five days and we are gonna
see who will be the final four to meet
in London just days after that as we go
into December
so Grantchester org has everything you
need to know but we already know that
Magnus Carlsen has punched his ticket to
to London and so he will be playing this
more or less an exhibition for the money
okay I don't know is that an exhibition
it's for the money and you'll see maybe
he tries to get the sense of the players
too you know he definitely could because
London will be a mix of all different
time controls but we're gonna have
Magnus Carlsen there Dingley Rin will
still be fighting to get to London
he's probably in but it's not guaranteed
because you also have Levon Aronian
Vishy Anand Wesley so young the pom
mushy all playing in India who could
make it to London and there's only four
spots and also on the sidelines
MVL could also still make it to London
if the stars align he's the only full
tour player who could still make the
London who's not playing in India so it
all starts on November 22nd it's the
Tata Steel India rapid and blitz for the
first time ever we hope you can join us
at Grantchester
dot org if you're in the u.s. it's gonna
be in the middle of the night stay up
with us it's gonna be a fun time okay if
we have standings I'd love to see them
the group a section is as follows yes
indeed Jeffrey Zhang has earned the top
spot coming out of today of course Reena
Juma buy of and Grigory Oberon are still
at play they could get up there two
three and a half before the day is done
we will wait and see and over in the B
group we had all but one game come to a
finish of course L Shan and Sergei are
still battling and Sergei has robbed and
Alexei Sorokin sit at the
after their drawers today three and a
half we're halfway home sabina to see
who will be the champion in the group a
and b sections of the winter classic i
know it's really exciting I can't
believe five rounds have passed by so
quickly it's always great when you're
working with you're having fun when when
you're working so hopefully everyone is
enjoying our commentaries with you and
with Caleb as well and yeah I'm looking
forward to the next four rounds I'm
still going to be watching these games
as we sign off on us chest champs
websites so hopefully everyone will do
that as well and looking forward to see
some more results but yeah that's sky
those are kind of my thoughts for the
day
the action continues at us chest champs
calm Caleb Denby will return tomorrow
and be with you until the end of the
tournament on Monday the 18th this show
was produced by the world's greatest
production B team Tony Chen is making
sure the stream was holding up today
Isaac's trance graphics graphics and
audio we have Danny Machuca as our
technical director my name is Ben Simon
for the former US Women's Champion woman
grandmasters sabina forager we say until
tomorrow so long from the show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you
you